the jurgen experience is it amazing to
you as somebody who spent so long
thinking about otherworldly visitors
that now
they're releasing all this information
and no one really cares well the world
is in such chaos
no one cares no one cares during the
middle of the obama administration when
everything was going great
it would be giant news and what is the
news even that the pentagon just can't
account for all these unidentified
flying objects yeah they don't know what
they are
some of them that could easily be drones
because they're not moving at
spectacular speeds
right they're just sort of like hovering
over aircraft carriers those could be
drones
they could be some new style of drone or
some new kind of technology that maybe
some foreign government has but there's
other ones
that were spotted by
air force pilots and then tracked and
they have
detailed data on the speed of these
things they have video of these things
going what appears to be
thousands of miles an hour
instantaneously
accelerating with no visible propulsion
system
no heat signature they don't know what
the [ __ ] this is this is from 2004 off
the nimitz
commander david fravor who is a fighter
jet pilot
is like like rock solid credentials you
can't
yeah and i've talked to the guy i had
him on my podcast and even better
he was on lex podcast and lex did an
even better job than i did and talked to
him for
two plus hours about this and
the guy's incredibly credible that
[ __ ] thing whenever he was tracking
went from the nimitz tracked it they
tracked it on radar they tracked it with
uh
their uh the the on board sensors the
the
the things they use for targeting enemy
crafts
they track this thing from the nimitz it
went 80
000 feet above sea level to 50 feet
in a second that's crazy they don't know
what the [ __ ] it is they don't know what
it is they know that it was jamming
their radar
they know it was jamming them and and
then it moved when it took off at insane
rates of speed they couldn't even
watch it it just it's gone and then it
re re-emerged at the cat point the cat
point is the predetermined location
where the jets are supposed to scramble
to
during this exercise so it's literally
saying i know where you guys are going
right you're going over here right
whatever the [ __ ] it is who knows but
does that mean
that it's from another planet no it
could be some
[ __ ] insane technology that the
military's developed that we don't know
it could be
because they're there have you seen that
[ __ ] where the military
there's patents for ufo type
see if you can find what those are
because they're developing
or at least they're they've attempted to
develop some sort of gravitational drive
that would indicate that at least
there's been some
thought about developing a craft like
that now
if you put a person in one of these
things and you shot them off thousands
of miles and now they turn into jello
right but who says it's a person who
knows we got a rover on mars right now
taking pictures there's a helicopter
attached to it right you got high
resolution photographs from mars
here it is dock show navy got ufo patent
granted by warning of similar chinese
tech advances
this is what i'm saying patent document
indicates the us
and china are actively actively
developing
radical new craft that seem eerily
similar
to ufos reported by navy pilots now
if they're if this is like on paper
somewhere
where they're trying to get patents and
they're telling you that chinese
the chinese the military already has
something like this
what we're getting is years later
right they've been probably developing
[ __ ] like this for forever so they
probably have
some sort of working thing that can move
in extraordinary ways we are not going
to care until there's a mars attack
style raid
on the white house like that movie yeah
if you're not gonna cut if you don't
land with ray guns and start blasting
people
i don't even give a [ __ ] like no one's
gonna care we're
real weird with it now i've always said
that if
aliens are real earth is the tijuana of
outer space you're not kidding and they
come down here when they're [ __ ] up
and they want to see a show
yeah that's exactly right and then
they're not trying to no one's trying to
save tijuana
no no nobody's thinking about it yeah
it's a place that you go and they
mention it in a movie yeah
every now and then i see a donkey show
yeah robert rodriguez features it in a
vampire movie and then you get out of
there
it it it's interesting it's the one
conspiracy that i've never gotten into
that much because there's
the the information is so tough to
come by that i've just always said if
it's i nothing would surprise me
nothing would surprise me there's
something going on
there's something going on but what that
something is remains to be seen have you
seen that video of the men in black
that walk into they walk into this
um it's just two very tall weird dudes
that walk into like a uh
hotel and then leave jamie you can find
it easily and it's just these guys that
were supposedly like
you know something weird happened and
supposedly they're guys that come
in like after something weird happens
and like
shut it down and they're both very tall
and very and i don't know if it's fake
or not i don't think it is fake though
but i don't know it could be fake
where where could one find this video
like it's on youtube or something jamie
can find it's the real men in black
it's like the real you know whatever you
know supposedly there was something that
happened
where i don't know somebody went in
after it like somebody had to go respond
to something and these two like
weird looking dudes came in very strange
there's got to be a man in black if
there are if we know about
there's got to be some uh part of the
government that deals with that
well there's two schools of thought
right one school of thought is that the
government is way too incompetent to
ever keep anything from anybody
that's not true that's not true right
and there's other schools of thought
where
you're like no they there's a perceived
buffoonery
that's attached to some level of
government because there's a lot of
people in government that are [ __ ]
idiots
right but at like there's a lot of
people that work at ups that are [ __ ]
idiots but if you get to the highest
levels of the organization you know what
they're doing yeah i mean if you're
going to ascend to the highest levels
of the cia or the nsa you're going to
probably be brilliant
right what are the odds that you're not
right you're probably going to have a
good person
no the best people uh but you're going
to
have
yeah foreign policy and how to
manipulate things did you not find the
men in black video
not really i found something but it was
like all it was animation and stuff it
wasn't really like a hotel
no i don't know if it was a hotel there
was just two guys that walked in
and then left and they looked the video
i found it's like a description of
events of like that happening i didn't
find it okay actual video i'm looking
well it's always been one of those
things a part of ufo folklore right
that these men and black folks yeah
they're like oddly fake
they look like fake looking skin show up
yeah
that's what i would do if i was gonna go
interview some guy about uh
ufos you know what i would do i'd put
like weird white makeup on yeah yeah
dress in a black suit and ask him
strange questions while wearing
sunglasses
yeah and i'd have him freak out why not
why not [ __ ] with him yeah why not leave
him
to the point where what he's gonna tell
all his friends is so crazy
no one's gonna believe it well that's
part of i think what what a lot of it is
imagine if you have an aircraft that's
shaped like a pyramid right
and you're flying it over philadelphia
yeah here it is okay
that's all it is i don't know what this
is yeah dudes wearing suits but it is to
me that proves yeah what is that
it proves it to me what does this say
that that proves it to me what is the uh
niagara falls show canceled what is that
immediately
okay finally we have perhaps the most
conclusive evidence of the real men in
black
hotel in canada and the manager was a
little disturbed
when his bell boy informed him that the
previous day
the hotel had been visited by two tall
men
dressed completely in black who demanded
to speak to him
maybe they were johnny cash fans yeah
so they're just men this is what's
ridiculous about conspiracy theories
those are two guys i have a suit do you
have a suit yes but i don't think they
have
eyebrows now that what is this they had
no eyebrows
oh see that's what i would do i would
[ __ ] shave my eyebrows
or put some makeup on over them so that
i look like a weirdo
and then make them real uncomfortable
when they're telling their friends man
yeah i [ __ ] believe this look at
these guys
here they are okay that's got to be from
a movie right what is that
what is that image from let that guy
play it out
that concludes our look at the men in
black but remember
guys these guys get striped just a
handful of real life accounts
involving these mystery men there are
many more stories to look at online
yeah there's a british there's the men
in black
there are many mysteries to look at as
long as there's more stories yeah online
is that that's more content online we
can sink our teeth into
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre in the background
while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience